from
theweek.com
court issues 10-day ban on honking in
downtown ottawa a canadian judge issued
a 10-day injunction monday banning
protesters protesting truckers from
honking their horns in downtown ottawa
quote tooting a horn is not an
expression of any great thought i'm
aware of justice hugh mclean of the
ottawa superior court said
he also said the ban on honking would
not rob demonstrators of their right to
protest
a convoy of truckers and other
demonstrators protesting canada's
covenanting policies entered on january
29th where they've been for some time
let me just let me just answer you know
respond to this year justice hugh mclean
honking absolutely is an expression of a
great thought he doesn't understand
memes but more importantly the state
this is canada by the way it's not the
u.s so they can have their backwards
garbage policies or whatever the state
should not be deciding what is someone's
expression
what comes next now people are saying
i'll just yell hunk i'll just get a
megaphone and just yell honk into it
okay well i think this is a ridiculous
this is ridiculous but i will say it
shows well the great honking has worked
it's worked to the point where a court
has had to issue one of the most
ridiculous injunctions i've ever heard
of honking is forbidden sounds like
they're going to try and get them out of
there now in the next 10 days they're
like let's buy ourselves a little time
we'll see if we can get them out if they
can't nine and a half days from now
they'll issue another ban for 10 more
days or whatever you know only 15 days
to slow the spread of these truckers
uh all around the country
i just i just think it's funny because
it's canada it's canada honking is
banned it's just this works on so many
levels right first people are posting
memes where they're like who would have
thought the answer to clown world would
have been honking i know it's just so
good and then you have it's happening in
canada of all places and they got the
goose yeah so it's just like we we we
live in some kind of constructed reality
i got a simulation let me put this on
the table but
i i've been thinking a lot about this
honking is
aggressive it can be very
it you could argue that it's a kind of
noise weapons are real you can destroy
someone with excessive amounts of noise
you can hurt someone with that cia knows
it they work with those things um so a
lot of noise is kind of can be
weaponized now
it's
then so like are they so apparently
these people are honking and they're
violating maybe civil rights noise
violations but for for the canadian
government to start to violate their
human rights of like
food and fuel seems like that's
stoking the bear well this is the great
canadian bear well this is a canadian
government though as we know was seizing
their gasoline too like that you know
they there's there's this uprising of of
workers that's and it's it's pissing off
the people in power in canada and it
seems that they'll go to great lengths
in order to shut them up
yeah no i mean i agree with you they're
basically placing sanctions on these
people and then they're arguing that
honking is an act of violence
honk yeah
i've been wondering so i was gonna say
ian i think you're i think you're not
quite rolling a one on this one okay i
got like three or something no maybe a
ten oh okay you know i think there's a
guy who's got a train horn
and people are laughing about it because
it's triggering people i'm like dude i
gotta be honest the train horn might be
a little much
like honking your horn is honking her
everybody's got one but mounting a train
horn to a vehicle and then blaring it
like
yeah i mean that that's that's not
helping your cause out you know honking
your horn is annoying protest as aoc
says are supposed to make people
uncomfortable so honking your horn hey
man more power to you uh
if they say hey guy you got you brought
a train horn into downtown ottawa i i'd
be like yeah dude that's like come on
it's a little much isn't it i mean it's
funny but it's when all the trucks come
together they create like a mega horn
which is like way worse than well the
way louder than a train horn i i'm i
don't know what to do because i support
these truckers implicitly i mean if i'm
thinking
i i want to i want to help the cause but
i will still acknowledge that this noise
can be used as a form of violence
and so i understand kind of both sides
of this yeah
but hold on hold on like what do you
mean by violence yeah like it can harm
like if i take a big loud speaker and
put it next to your head and yeah do it
you'll be like ah and then it'll hurt
your hearing and then it might even
start to make you make you angry which
makes you stressed that it well it can
be really annoying but it's not like the
truckers are going he supports the
mandates get him and then like putting
their head next to the horn and honking
so they go deaf i mean they're just
they're they're honking their horns in a
way that makes people uncomfortable you
also have to consider that these
truckers themselves are here day in and
day out and it's going to get annoying
to them on some level so i think they
can self-regulate here i think it's
insane the canadian government would
tell them they're not able to express
themselves in this way like i could like
i could see if you're a citizen in
ottawa and living in downtown ottawa and
all day every day all you hear is hong
kong honk i could see how that would get
annoying at the same time it's not like
they're burning your buildings down like
in other protests that we've seen before
so i could see how that would be
annoying but like but the government but
like did the government step in like
this like in the summer of 2020 in
canada or in the united states well how
bad were the riding how bad was the
writing in canada though i honestly
don't know well the movement was
everywhere yeah but what might not have
been bad as america but was
black canadian lives matter like
smashing windows and burning buildings
probably not as bad as america but the
movement was you know they wouldn't but
it but like you know
again it's the politics behind this i
don't think you know
you know
i just searched ottawa on twitter i saw
this video i think yesterday which is
what brought this up in my mind is a guy
in ottawa got his videos like hey guys
just so you know this is what it's like
all day and it's like
just non-stop so i understand i would go
freaking crazy if all of a sudden i on
whatever uh backstage i'd support her
all of a sudden just maddening noise all
around me yeah you know i don't care uh
you wanna know why the insurance
companies will pay for it yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah so if you get if you get
ear damage you got insurance what's
what's problem it's a language of the
unheard um
actually i don't i don't agree with that
yeah no it's a ridiculous notion yeah
but uh i i don't i don't actually care
about the discomfort of these people
because
as the government was ruling by decree
they sat back and said sure and then
when the government started cracking
down on the truckers imposing will by
decree on them and the trucker said stop
the people sat in their homes and said
hey i'm not getting involved i don't
care they're doing it to you in fact
i'll vote for them and empower them and
pay them money and ensure they can keep
putting their boot on your net and then
the trucker said i'm gonna toot yeah
come on honk honk another like stop
walking no sorry buddy
ian i mean you're absolutely right that
it is extremely annoying and if these
people were outside of my window honking
i would be annoyed as well but at the
same time if it's a question of whether
we're going to allow a group of people
to be annoyed or allow group people to
have their rights violated i'm going to
choose to let those people be annoyed
yeah you said that was pretty insightful
what you said just a second ago tim
about how like because i'm thinking
about the german citizens when they
supported just allowed the nazis to do
their thing just stood by and let it
happen when the allied troops came in
there they didn't
you know those people they had to sit by
and listen to the honking they weren't
allowed to be like stop you know you
said i just
sit by and watch tyranny take hold get
ready to face some repercussions it's
not just that it's a lot of these people
are voting in these politicians over and
over again like they vote for trudeau
they vote for the people who are putting
in place these mandates so it's like
listen
we want you to hear the repercussions of
your actions elections have consequences
ottawa votes for these people i'm sorry
you know it's funny i'll tell you this
the people who live in ottawa
who uh who don't vote for this are
outside dancing in the streets cheering
on the trucks and the protests that's
people who that's that's the people who
live in ottawa i i'm not gonna like i
live there i've watched some of the live
streams i watched viva fry he's got a
great stream and i've seen a lot of the
videos and there's people with canadian
flags jumping up and down they're
celebrating these are people who live in
the city the people who are screaming
and complaining about the honking are
the people who did not are the people
who did vote for trudeau and don't
support the truckers i don't care if if
look
if you come out and say you that you
voted for joe biden i'm going to be like
okay well now you're going to be
uncomfortable
uncomfortable for having supported a man
who's caused all of these problems for
us the death of the of the civilians in
afghanistan the rising gas prices the
failing economy there's some good things
about the economy but you can't come out
and be like we lost two million jobs and
brought back 1.5 so we're doing great
like no you're doing bad and if you want
to come out and be like you supported
him then i'll be like prepare to be
uncomfortable as i protest the guy you
voted in yeah no i mean
i think that when you're
you're looking at this situation
and these mandates and the fact that
these people were completely in favor of
them and that's resulted in these
protests and now they're really upset by
the honking
you kind of have to put it in
perspective ultimately what's going to
make their lives worse
the hyperinflation which is occurring uh
because we decided to print trillions of
dollars the broken supply chains the
fact that it's more difficult different
countries
it's true but also our economies are
really interconnected and if the dollar
isn't doing it strongly and we're not
trading with them as much or the supply
chain has broken down in our country
that's going to affect their lives too
and a couple horns honking outside your
window day in and day out for as long as
this protests last is not going to have
as much of a negative effect on their
lives in the long term the other thing
you have to think about is like the the
people doing the honking and the
protesting these are the people who
during the pandemic while everyone was
all them were staying inside these are
the people who were you know bringing
you your packages to your door bringing
the supplies everywhere that was
probably more annoying than just hearing
some honks every day i'm sure they're
like
dude
it's amazing these are these are people
who
sit inside
vote for politicians who lock everything
down and then demand a government just
give them money yeah i saw a tweet from
this girl i don't remember who but it
was like a journalist and she was like
who do we have to appeal to to save us
from this was basically the tweet and
i'm like there's a mindset of huma in
humanity of like where is daddy to save
me
who's gonna come fix this and it's like
dude you fix it it's you seriously these
are the these people love to be like i'm
going to to vote for the authority to do
whatever they want then go and sit back
and say solve my problems for me
that vote causes problems for everybody
else who are now dancing in the street
and honking horns not even smashing
windows or anything like that
and now these people are crying about it
dude i have i have very little sympathy
i'm sorry man that's just that's just
reality these people need to live in the
real world you know i i we've talked
about the fourth turning we've talked
about you know hard times make strong
men strong men make good times good
times weak men etc and this is the
problem with a lot of these people who
live in these big cities they want
everything done for them
they get paid
ridiculous salaries for ridiculous jobs
not everybody but a lot of them the
people like in new york it's really bad
but there's a lot of city jobs that make
no sense
and they've just not experienced any
real hardship this is the first time i
think about how crazy this is there's
that video of the guy who looks like the
pregnant man emoji have you seen this
wearing the blue jacket and he's got
like the belly so people have put the
pregnant man emoji on him and he's like
i can't sleep ah i'm losing my mind or
whatever and it's like
bro calm down
you know you know you know
this is the reason why i have very
little sympathy is probably because
i lived i lived on a busy street and i
hear honking all day every day non-stop
but i've also experienced you know
actual hardship and so when i hear
people screaming and crying about
honking i'm like geez yeah where did
they grow up inside like a fluffy padded
room that was like pastel colors with
animals painted on the wall west well
that's a very interesting point because
ottawa is one of the richest cities in
canada and so for months at least in the
united states you had blm burning down
some of the most impoverished
neighborhoods in the country and making
life impossible for the people who lived
there and our media thought that that
was just fine but now when working-class
people go into an upper-class
neighborhood and honk their horns too
loudly for too long it's a nightmare i
will say as much as they are it is a
different country
our culture completely overlaps exactly
so the you've got american leftist
journalists
who are on the side of the government of
canada and then you've got american you
know libertarian conservative moderate
post liberals who are on the side of the
great honkening i i genuinely believe
you know 90 plus percent of people
support the hunkening you know you're
never going to convince me because i i
look at the comments on reddit even the
astroturfing isn't working and i'm just
like i'm sorry man
i don't i just won't believe that actual
grassroots regular leftists i don't mean
online personalities regular people that
if you go to them and say how do you
feel about the workers rising up that
was pretty cool how do you feel about
the truckers rising i'm glad they're
glad they're rising up against the
establishment yeah no
and that's sort of my point even though
yes obviously this is occurring in a
different country our media is going to
empathize with the upper class people
who are being inconvenienced in canada
more so than they would lower class
people in the united states having their
actual business burnt down
well it goes to
i mean it goes to show that the media
speaks for the interests of you know the
ruling class and the powerful and even
in canada where the media is actually
controlled by the government like the
media are actual government entities so
you know it's in that case they're
actually on the side of the government
and like i was looking at some of the
coverage in canadian media and i was
like yeah you can really tell yeah it's
it's amazing one of the first articles
we read on the show it was like the far
right group that has been known for
vandalism and stealing food from the
homeless exactly exactly dude that's
just not true now there's this there's
this story did you guys hear about these
guys trying to break into a building and
burn it down with people inside no and
and these left-wing activists many
americans
there well quote-unquote journalists are
trying to claim that it's definitive and
proven
bro it's a video of two guys we don't
know who they are they walk in a
building set fire something on the
ground and then take the door shut and
leave that's crazy arrest those guys
but then they're just like this proves
it thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you